my opponent tonight is a former Rhodes
Scholar the former mayor of Newark and
the current senator from New Jersey
senator Cory Booker thank you for coming
I'd also like to take Aiden for let s
use his room here this is pretty great
room a big fan of trains you know where
you're going with the Train yes yes you
got to stay on track in life it's a very
good metaphor exactly yes I want to stay
on track yes we got some kids here
yes there's a big March coming on can
you just can you just tell them that
this is a fad and it's time to move on
what do you think about this March well
two things one is you have to understand
that changed has never in history come
from Washington it's come to Washington
Strom Thurmond didn't just one day say
hey I think those black folks should
have some civil rights Noah was people
that marched and demonstrated and
brought change to Washington what
they're doing is not only consistent
with history it's actually been the only
pathway that real meaningful change has
been made is through the activism of
young Americans so you're supporting
these kids are they they bullied you
what I'm seeing right now smoking some
doobies up by the people I think that
what these guys are doing is leading by
example they're letting adults know you
guys haven't been able to make change we
have a horrific reality where every day
in America dozens of people are dying
due to gun violence and that this has to
stop you guys haven't stopped it so
we're gonna take the helm and leave the
change what's what's adults problems I
mean I know I'm fine
I got what I I want change not happening
status quo thumbs up but you're an adult
you're an adult in a position of power
wise and change happening from your
right well first of all it's very
frustrating I know I know what captures
a lot of attention is often the mass
shootings these awful awful realities
but every day in America we have lots of
shootings in communities like mine I've
had two shootings on my block and last
year--last most recently last week
jihad Smith was killed by an automatic
weapon at the top of the block of where
I live I live in an inner-city
low-income community and so this is
hurtful that we have not been able to
make change and a lot of the times the
people in power often don't represent
the views Republican or Democrat of
their majority they're citizens and so
this is at the time where the people
want change they want
and sense gun safety measures be done
but the people and power are doing
anything and I think what these young
people gonna show what the truth in any
democracy is that the power of the
people is greater than the people in
power
you mentioned mass shootings and this
movement seems to be a response to
school shootings but mass shootings are
only three percent of the gun deaths in
America in 2017 is this a misguided
movement or they focusing on the wrong
things
no I fact I've heard incredible
eloquence by a lot of young people
around the country and people from
Parkland even people in New Jersey have
been saying hey look we're gonna use
this moment to shine a light on the fact
that we have in many poor communities in
communities of color that deaths are
happening every day and for some reason
nobody's paying attention because again
this is not a problem that we can't do
something about we have the power to
make change and so what this is a
question of not is can we is but do we
have the collective will and I think
what they're doing is waking up the
moral imagination of this country
pointing to the moral urgency and
they're in turn determined to keep it
going now you're talking a lot about
people coming together and that's just
what you do you love to talk about that
Wayne LaPierre talked about you and your
European socialism to guns
yes you just want everybody to share one
gun is that your ultimate vision for
America you know when our founders came
together and the end of the Declaration
of Independence with these noble words
that if this country is going to work we
must mutually pledge to each other you
know they said our Lives our Fortunes
and our sacred honor this is a country
have rugged individualism and it's a
country of self-reliance but we also
have proven to humanity
you know rugged individualism didn't get
us to the moon that when we come
together and work together and partner
we can do things that are beyond the
imagination of our ancestors you really
think we went to the moon I hate to do
this because this is my show but I have
children here and apparently they have
questions so if you don't mind there's
some questions that you're giving over
some of your platforms because I'm an
adult and I think we should talk down to
children doesn't mean I'm always gonna
talk I was wondering about this
positioning you put them on the floor
and you had us Lord above the young
people this is just functionally in the
best position
don't let the metaphor play out that I'm
literally talking down to children yeah
that's what I want all right all right
well even though they're lower than us
we will let's look up to them and and
their stature so come on mr. Bowker
you're thinking we're talking to me
today the Democratic Party has helped my
movement by giving us a platform and
we've been speaking a lot about change
when will you actually propose any
change right well I'm hopeful that this
is gonna this election in November is
gonna be a referendum and I don't want
to be a partisan election this is not a
simply about left or right or Republican
or Democrat it's to me it's about right
or wrong and if you are a person
standing up and blocking if you're in
Congress right now and you're blocking
what 90% of Americans want some of these
common-sense things and you need to be
voted out of office because you are
being complicit or in action as being
complicit in the continued violence my
favorite question you've talked about a
lot of stuff I have no idea about and it
really didn't stick so I'd like you to
tell me something I already know well I
think you know that the the long arc of
history bends towards justice we were a
country that's gotten better and better
and better isn't that where it goes it
does it absolutely does but it doesn't
Bend automatically we've got to be the
benders and so the right side of history
right now is finding the common ground
and doing those things that will make
America safer yeah I totally knew that
all right senator Cory Booker